One of the most powerful features of MongoDB is the ability
to query against fields that are not simply scalar values such as
strings or integers. But those that are themselves structured data such
as a arrays. As we know, MongoBD can have rate values and
you see a couple of examples, right here on the screen.
We can query within arrays with a couple of different ways. Now
I think the best example from the Autos collection actually has
to do with model years. So let's take a look at that.
Now the simplest example is to provide a single value
for model years in our query document. Let's see what happens.
So in this case we can see that
our model years here, for this particular vehicle are
1975 through 1980. And we queried with just
1980. Even though the value for model years fields
is an array, this value will match. MongoDB
searches inside array value fields, for individual values to
match. And by building an index on a fields
such as this, those queries will be very efficient.